with Lee off for interference not even
5 minutes in as czas is going to catch
up to this Puck first behind the net the
Gap closed by Mar but cikas playing keep
away and Clutterbuck had it Stripped by
marar got away from marar pelic stepped
up couldn't get it into the Zone
ran it over for Johansson and he
scores in transition it's a power play goal the
change up of a one-time from Jo hon got by sokin
he overplayed it well not really he just can't
anticipate the guy's going to give you a knuckle
ball at that time but Adam pel gets caught in
the neutral zone there's a backhand pass and
look at that it's just it's just a floater and
sorokin's there in plenty of time ma starts the
play off and then a beautiful pass by Ranon on
a backhander but look at this he just fans on it
his arm is outstretched and it goes R between
the blocker and the body so tough break for
soken first seven shots belong to Colorado and
now they're on their second power play just 23
seconds after the Johansson goal and Nathan
McKinnon had an open net it wouldn't go Ryan
poock I think got a stick on it and sent it
across the goal mou he just continues to make
plays like this well he's going to have multiple
saves of the year and the in the National Hockey
League and there's one with the paddle but just
just stays right with it he's driving behind the
net NuSkin worked around ranted and across the
ice off the STI pone Colton fights it out top
for McKinnon over ranted it slips it in front
and the toe of soken kept it out was uh looked
like he was guessing a little bit guess right and
that's another one like that's just unbelievable
as you said he he makes it look like it's just
routine well now it's starting to become routine
isn't it Steel by Paso sent up top here's doson
with a BL and he scores Cal Clutterbuck with a
tip just outside the crease and just like that
and we're TI at one and that's just a huge goal
for the alers I mean they needed and they a good
little chip into the corner yoria doesn't handle
it very well Hao steals the puck makes a good
cross- eyes pass and homom is in front and look
where the stick is for Clutterbuck perfect
position what a great look at that and as a
defenseman my first look was always to the side
of the net your knck this one given up with the
line Taves came off the bench and misfired on a
pass on a working its way to ranin and then Mar
came in over skated to the puck comes out in the
neutral zone while the outs make a change marar
back in as ranin came out and the back hands
one home enough to check the entry as ranin
was on his way out of the Zone while Mar was
coming in but that's the kale marar show it's
2-1 Colorado he has such a turn of speed let's
see if that was offside or not no it doesn't
look like it huh or maybe at the bottom right
too Brendan sure the Islanders are checking it
no I guess they're not going to bother with I
take another look here that's close huh close
yeah Islanders start Paso Clutterbuck
and Holstrom with Dobson and pelic this
is The Islander line that produced their goal
for the first period and they're matched up
against McKinnon pal Mar around towards barzel
Nelson's all the way across barzel will work
it high for Thompson returned it barzel Paul
maray goal line shoot [Applause] scores Kyle
P Mar on the power play and the Islanders tying
at two great Puck movement there by the by the
Islanders well you can see barel down low takes a
little look and I watch the shift of the players
as eventually Paul Murray number 21 is going to
come down low Corvette to The Far Side and that's
maybe just enough of a distraction one of the big
triggers for every single penalty kill is if the
guy doesn't have possession and now it's Pou and
Holstrom up bikes Holstrom left side working on
the car to the net goes Paso in the Stick of
Gorgan forced that one away from the Ed now
it's Clutterbuck to the front homest [Applause]
scar Simon Holstrom and the Islanders have taken
the [Music] lead this is a tremendous play it
starts off with a pass from Clutterbuck at the
middle to Paso then h takes a look good job there
driving to the net by Pou the watch Holstrom gets
into the slot area doesn't waste any time and goes
up in the toy department so that line develops a
little bit of chemistry and boy oh boy those are
the things that the coaching staff are waiting
to see on a constant basis from from Holstrom
perhaps he's found his linemates one shot on
net for that two-minute power play for New York
slipped on for NuSkin B NuSkin the Byam Byrum has
space in the middle and he scores bow and Byam
blocker side on soken and it's 33 here late in
the second yeah there was a little bit of a mix
up in the dzone by the island there's plenty of
guys back but little confusion who should take
by watch the Islanders as they're all back in
this situation quick dumpen and here's where the
problem starts a little quick turnaround look at
all the Islanders are all back but who who's going
out there nobody knows who to go confusion in that
scenario and he gets too good an opportunity and
I'm not that might deflected off a off a player
in front McKinnon was there but that was a so it
have been a long time since they had a come back
like that this one wouldn't be as dramatic but
it would be their second comeback of the night
after they fell behind no linesman down there to
even call it that was interesting they said it
hit his stick so gave him the benefit of the doubt
here's Lee pulled it away from Jo P it strong on
his skates risks the shot and scores oh tight one
missed that one great effort by Andrew Leo I mean
he just refused to give up on the puck kept this
balance he was kind of stumbling here and there GE
just missed Brendon it's a good play off the wall
Thomas St get into this position yeah and Anders
it's Puck protection first right that's his game
and for him that's from downtown that's long range
but he got a lot on that I gorv is going to want
it back no question that's why I I took physics
and stuff like that I'm good with numbers the
first thing I think of about you there's a shot
block at the line by Tatar trying to turn on
pelic Tatar over SK to the pck picked up his
head found Ranon and who scores M Ranon and gives
Colorado back the lead after a great play by Tomas
tar and the Avalanche sort of won the the puck
and Adam pic shot is blocked but doesn't look
like there's a lot of danger right there
and then just quick little two onone and
that just a great shot just a quick release
right away but great play by tar along the
boards goes right underneath the pad of soken
we saw Brock Nelson score one against Devon
Levi 115 left as Barelle looks over his
options drags it into the crease with a
sharp angled shot off the paths of gorgia
coming around again it's Horvat a pass
flaged down by Ranon it flipped ahead Horvat
trying to catch him Johansson will put it
away the Islanders came back and tied this game
three different times including once in the third
period had some some opportunities they pulled the
goenda on many occasions nothing really happens
tonight ORV that on the forehand came out of the
pile and it's Pou who has the puck Nelson moves
it in a hurry and too much of a hurry this may be
an on goal yeah that's going in anyway oh boy oh
somebody for Colorado will get credit for it Brock
Nelson was the last to touch it and an empty net
makes it 74 it's like Colton's taking credit for
it it's a freebie on the statute yep absolutely a
plus also for the guys on the ice and there's no
way that anybody can catch that an unsuccessful
power play for the Islanders in the second period
that really wanted being the difference in the
game despite the fact that the Islanders did
come out and tie this score in the third period
early on on the goal from Manders Lee but Colorado
improves to 6 and0 as they beat the ERS 74 tonight